Rogan with Mar discussing how the woke
and the extremists have destroyed the
term liberal something you all know well
about but it is worth repeating because
those are the people that we got to save
if I said so many of the things that
I've said on Club random on a podcast on
Real Time on HBO
they would have had my head yeah but
somehow when I say it in the setting of
the podcast in my own home blowing the
pot smoke
somehow it's okay and I find that very
interesting I think they look at you
like a guy who they're worried about
because you don't toe the line they
should be you you're like a 90s liberal
you like liberals back when they're more
reasonable before they became leftists
and now every liberal kind of has to be
a leftist it's not it's not if you want
to be on the team you got to subscribe
to the most Fringe ideas that the team
is promoting and I get in trouble with
that too it's just it's such a I mean
there's so many like Joe list has talked
about that recently in the comic show
list very funny guy he was talking about
like he's like I'm a 90s liberal he goes
what I didn't change it's like everybody
else kind of changed it just got real
weird like what you're allowed to
disagree with and not to disagree with
and
you know yes I'm strange I'm always
trying to make the case
that liberal is a different animal than
woke
yeah because it is and you can be woke
with all the nonsense that that now
implies
um but don't say that somehow it's an
extension of liberalism right because
it's most often actually an undoing of
liberalism so you can have your points
of view and your positions on these
things but don't try to piggyback on
what I've always believed I have always
believed as liberals do for example in a
colorblind society that the goal is to
not see race at all anywhere for any
reason yes that's what liberals always
believed all the way through Obama going
back Kennedy everybody Martin Luther
King that's not what the woke believe
they believe race is first and foremost
the thing you should always see
everywhere which I find interesting
because that used to be the position of
the Ku Klux Klan
that we see race first and foremost
everywhere yeah uh so again you can have
that position but don't say that's a
liberal position you're doing something
very different I think the idea behind
it I think I understand their idea the
idea is that the society is imbalanced
and so in order to address that
imbalance you're going to prop up as
many minorities as possible make as many
opportunities for minorities as possible
and get it to a position where there are
like white people are minority and so
that's not a concern anymore and that
through that somehow or another you'll
achieve equality
I think the way to achieve equality is
your way I think the colorblind way is
the way to really truly achieve equality
and to truly judge people just on their
merits so if you Bill Maher want to live
this with love Bill if you build more
and you Joe Rogan if you want to live in
that colorblind Society you cannot vote
for Democrats you cannot yes you can say
and it's the same thing I said when I
had RFK Jr on here about two months ago
it's like you're you're still sort of
thinking of the Democrats of yesteryear
as if they're the Democrats of today so
I get it you can name a lot of old
Democrats I can name a whole bunch of
dead Democrats who made a lot of sense
years ago but
Joe we're not in the 90s anymore so Joe
if I'm not mistaken doesn't vote I could
be wrong on this I'd be happy to be
corrected if I am uh but he he I guess
didn't have the balls or he can talk
about politics all day long but didn't
vote I actually don't even mean that as
an attack on him what I'm saying is now
get to the conclusion you gotta damn
well vote for Trump or DeSantis or
whoever it's going to be on the
Republican side if we we have any chance
to get out of this right and and Bill
you can't the day before the the
midterms like you did uh just about 10
months ago you can't say you have to
vote Democrat if you want to save
democracy all the while the house is
burning
and we got bigger problems